hey everyone this is Lucy and in this
video we're going to be covering a
highly requested video topic which is
how to document your AWS Cloud projects
many of you who are learning AWS know
that cloud projects are a great way to
build your technical skills but the
question that often comes up is how do
you showcase these projects when
applying to a job well there are a few
ways to do this and here are the three
methods we'll be covering in today's
video the first one is by showcasing
your projects on a personal portfolio
website the second one is by creating a
GitHub repository for your projects and
the third one is by using social media
platforms like medium and Linkedin for
each of these I'll provide step-by-step
instructions on how you can get started
as well as some examples of how other
people have used these methods to
document their Cloud projects let's get
into it so method number one is to
document your Cloud projects through a
personal portfolio website this is one
of the most common ways to Showcase your
projects because it will not only help
you build a personal brand but also
maximize your chances of getting hired
into a cloud role you can kind of think
of a portfolio website as the central
place for you to store and Link
everything together this could include
your resume AWS Cloud projects as well
as any blog articles you've written
pretty much anything that can help
showcase your skills and experiences for
instance if you create a 3T web
application on AWS you could include a
project section in your portfolio and
document it there but at this point some
of you might be thinking okay Lucy what
exactly do you mean by document what are
the key components I should include well
it's really up to you because there's no
one correct way of doing this but what I
would recommend is to start by writing a
summary of what you built the steps you
took and what services used you could
also include an architectural diagram
and any screenshots of the process and
if you want to go a step further one
more option is to create a YouTube video
to demonstrate how the application works
the main point is to make sure the
documentation is clear and easy to
understand okay let me show you some
examples I came across where people have
added Cloud projects to their portfolio
so this first example is from adita
pretama he's a site reliability engineer
based in Indonesia and does a really
good job at showcasing all of his
experiences in cloud and it if we click
on the project section you can see that
a data has created a list of personal
projects that he's worked on in the past
let's take a look at this AWS serverless
web application project so in this
article there's a little introduction
section explaining why the project was
built and if we scroll down a bit more
we can see the diagram of the
architecture and the services used this
is Then followed by a step-by-step
summary of how the project was built so
that if someone were to try and build
the exact same project they'll be able
to follow along the instructions I'll
leave a link down below if you'd like to
check out adita's website and let's move
on to another example of a portfolio
website this next example is a portfolio
website created by Marika Bergman Marika
is a freelance full stack developer and
on her website she documents her AWS
Cloud projects and certification badges
in the project section she highlights
two technical projects one of them being
the cloud resume challenge if we hover
over the box you can see that she has a
blog post about the project as well as
the front end and back end of the
projects stored on GitHub let's take a
look at her blog post about the cloud
resume challenge so similar to the
previous example Marika also shares some
context on why she decided to build the
project and she also included an
architectural diagram of what she built
but what I really like about this post
in particular is that she takes more of
a personal approach and talks about
things that she found challenging for
example having to choose between a rest
API and a HTTP API to create your own
portfolio website I'll recommend using a
website builder instead of trying to
build it from scratch so that you can
hover up and running much faster let me
show you a quick demo of how to get
started so I'm using hostinger one of my
favorite web hosting platforms and if
you click on the link below you'll be
able to get a special discount on their
annual subscription okay let's click on
claim deal and here I'd recommend going
with the premium web hosting option this
one lets you create up to 100 websites
and also provides you with a free custom
domain which I find quite useful let's
click add to cart and choose a period
I'm going to choose the 48 month option
since it offers the best value and also
because I want my websites to be up and
running in the long term and before you
make the purchase remember to use the
code Tech with Lucy in this coupon code
section over here to get an even bigger
discount now once you've signed up
you'll see this hostinger dashboard and
the option to claim your free domain I'm
going to type in Lucy awsproject.com and
you can choose any domain name you'd
like check for the availability and
complete registration cool so now I'm
ready to build my portfolio website and
what's really great about hostinger is
that they now have an AI website builder
option so you can just type in what
website you need and they will generate
something that's tailored to what you're
looking for okay so here I'll type in
personal portfolio website for AWS
projects
awesome so here's the website they
generated and I can customize it to make
it look exactly the way I want if you'd
like to build your own website using
hostinger you can head to hostinger.com
forward slash Tech with Lucy to get a
limited time discount on all the yearly
plans but yeah overall I'd highly
recommend building a portfolio website
because it would not only help you keep
track of everything you built but also
make it easier for you to present your
projects to potential employers the
second way to document your AWS Cloud
projects is by using GitHub GitHub is
widely used in the tech industry and is
a great way to document your AWS card
projects now instead of walking you
through the stages of creating a GitHub
account and storing your projects let me
show you a great example of one so here
we have the GitHub page of verbal Junior
devops engineer if we click on the
repositories tab you can see that he has
a repository named AWS projects where he
stores a copy of all the cloud projects
that he has worked on there's five Cloud
projects in this repo for example one of
them is a data migration project and
another is a web app project let's take
a look at the web app project folder and
see what's inside Okay cool so Robo has
created a web application for an example
organization called Holden school and
has packaged up his project in a cloud
formation template he included the
architectural diagram as well as
detailed instructions on how to
configure the project if you'd like to
check out the rest of his GitHub repo
I'll leave a link to it in the
description below now the third way to
document your AWS Cloud projects is by
leveraging platforms like medium and
Linkedin this is one of my favorite ways
that I've seen people document the AWS
Car Projects because with those
platforms you can reach a broader
audience which then of course may lead
to more job opportunities similar to the
previous two methods I would recommend
including a description of the project
the AWS Services you used as well as any
relevant diagrams or screenshots and
again don't shy away from discussing any
challenges you faced and how you tackled
them here's an example of someone who
followed one of my YouTube tutorials and
published a LinkedIn article to document
it so this article is written by Sachin
ADI and he talks about how he visualized
data with Amazon quickside and Amazon S3
at the very top of the article we can
straight away see the architectural
diagram and as we scroll down a bit more
we can find a step-by-step walkthrough
with screenshots to Showcase every stage
what I like about his screenshots is
that they provide extra detail through
red boxes and numbers and what that does
is it shows people what exactly they
need to click on at each step alright
something we haven't covered in this
video yet is how to add Cloud projects
onto your resume this is a cloud
computing resume template that I've
shared in previous videos and I'll
include a link to it in the description
below but as you can see here all you
really have to do is include the name of
your project and a short description of
what you built you could also include a
hyperlink to your GitHub or portfolio
page in order to provide more details so
there you have it three effective ways
to document your AWS Cloud projects and
build a strong portfolio if you found
this video helpful please remember to
give it a like and as always I'll see
you in the comments below alright bye
for now